she would love you at the World Cup
um I don't know how you're doing how are
you doing any any chance I'm working on
it
um I mean the team's out next week so
yeah obviously everyone will find out
then but yeah it may be a little bit too
soon for me can can England win the
world cup and
not Leah
do they still have the strength in depth
to do well we have the quality we have
the quality player obviously you've seen
that the players that come off the bench
for us in the Euros they made a
difference and now it's they've got to
step up they've got a start and the
girls that were you know Fringe players
they've now got a step up and come and
make that difference when they come on
the pitch but I have everything the team
the players and the the out the England
outfit that they'll do everything in the
power to try and Win It